[Musique]
donc on a amassé de 60 ans avec une
insuffisance respiratoire hypoxie mixer
moubarak au vide le plus probable mais
je trouvais qu'ils étaient vraiment prêt
car au niveau respiratoire donc donc il
répond sur l'avant il répond sans
l'avant ouais le ton ami a besoin de
retrouver un peu de son voyage sur l'île
gauche ce qui m'inquiète chez lui
présentement à ces espèces de renvoyer
médicaux mais confortable hibou j'adore
un peu perdu et confus et senans levé
son ex-gendre c'est quelqu'un que
vraiment besoin de surveillance
aïe you know it's coved un des
déterminants de boscoville maintenant on
est prêt à y aller tu va le mettre sur
l'ex 20 à 100 % pour le voyage de mam
est ici délicat dans le transport c'est
que on peut pas y donner autant que
d'oxygène qu'est-ce qui est besoin c'est
que l'on y met le maximum qu'on peut le
but c'est de se rendre le plus vite
possible ou soit êtes en ciel pour lui
redonner l'oxygène et il faut traverser
le monde s'adapte en live à blida
amener des grandes respirations
ça va le rester assez célèbre il ya des
gens qui sont encore dans le baby je
peux difficilement comprendre pourquoi
mais jaser avec des amis pascal qui
m'expliquait que pour certaines
personnes
l'anxiété créé par la coved est
tellement grande que c'est plus simple
de nier l'existence même de kobe de ce
mécanisme de défense
j'ai des gens qui sont morts en millions
qu'ils avaient la commune
j'ai une personne que maintenu jusqu'à
la fin qu'est-ce que polak ovine qui est
en train de tuer bonjour jean marie
laborde en moins malade comme tout le
monde l'aurait tout de mettre un
scaphandre mieux moi
[Musique]
comment vous avez attrapé à la cage vide
j'ai créé soit un homme un deuxième job
ou soit l'école les enfants
c'est le 25 décembre que j'ai pris là
l'ambulance pour me dire ok c'est pas un
peu particulier puis j'ai perdu
quasiment toute la force du hezbollah
en fait je pourrais pas beaucoup de le
bouger c'est mon nom un prénom
je suis droitier lui en fait il est
l'exemple de tout ce qui peut aller mal
pendant une hospitalisation qu'ovide et
sa maladie augmente et on est obligé de
l'accueillir aux soins intensifs
déjà c'est un patient qui était très
nerveux de savoir comment ça allait se
manifester dans les prochains jours
qu'il est tranquillement ils voyaient
chacune de ces complications l'eau
arrivait ce que vous avez eu peur j'ai
laissé semaine tu te dis j'ai repensé sa
portion oui mon école je trouve pas
drôle ça a été un fait un moment que je
sais pas exactement quand même temps
j'ai pensé dans les comment puis je
m'ennuie de ma femme mes enfants mes
collègues de travail est-ce que vous
pouvez voir personnes 600 personnes non
lui c'est une aventure qui va durer ou
un bon 8 mois au parlement cet été il
devrait être pas mal fonctionnel
peut-être un retour au travail peut-être
à l'automne et on parle de quelqu'un qui
est dans quarantaine ça c'est quelqu'un
qui était qu'elle avait pas de problèmes
de santé c'est quelqu'un qui a un pied
dans la force de l'ange la pratique
[Musique]
pour nous la situation qu vide s'est
stabilisée ce plateau au pic de la
deuxième vague on avait douze treize
quatorze patients dans la zone qu'ovide
peut être un peu plus long est rendue
plus haut taux de 8 dans ces eaux là
mais l'achalandage des soins demeure
510% lors il va parce qu'on s'attend à
on n'a pas de détresse on n'aura pas
besoin d'une éducation pour m l'urgence
chaleur qui n'avait pas l'air si malade
tout ça oui alors c'est une des
particularités des patients avaient
cliqué avec la commune c'est que ceux
qui se détériore peuvent se détériorer
extrêmement rapidement
je trouve que ça a progressé très vite
pour quelqu'un qui était assez bien pour
aller au travail ce matin aux soins
intensifs on est toujours habitués de
travailler dans l'urgence
c'est un peu ce qui fait qu'on aime les
soins intensifs ce qui est lourd
actuellement c'est justement c'est le
la charge de travail on n'est pas formé
comme infirmière le pur est au front on
n'est pas des infirmières de guerre
fondée dans l'adaptation en continu à
tous les jours il faut qu'on se pose des
questions à savoir mon mais est ce que
c'est encore les bons protocole est ce
que c'est encore la bonne chose qu'on
fait ce que ça le change et 80 nous
donner le go on va pour qu'ils ne
retrouvent plus beaux la pression est
belle le but de la position ventrale
c'est vraiment de faciliter
l'oxygénation c'est de s'assurer que le
s'en vont là où le poumon et le moins
malade c'est quelque chose qui relève un
peu fou à faire mais ça fonctionne
extrêmement bien l oms 9 le set sur m et
1,92
c'est beaucoup de préparation ça demande
beaucoup de personnel comme vous avez pu
voir on était coiffé 7 environ c'est
très lourd chez des patients qui ont
souvent besoin de beaucoup beaucoup
d'oxygène
puis des passages sont difficiles à
venturi parce que c'étaient des pachas
qui sont un syndrome de détresse
respiratoire aiguë ça c'est un monsieur
qui hier jaser comme on se parle
présentement avait besoin d' excuse mais
tu es capable de parler avec sa famille
il s'est rapidement dégradée en soirée
hélas aujourd'hui on est obligé
d'utiliser la position ventrale votre
canne elle est en migration ce sens ils
vont relativement bien distincts mais
j'avais un autre patient est fière
qu'elle est super bien et est décédé
dans l'espace d'une heure et c'est rare
mais ça nous rappelle que ça pourrait
arriver et ça ne rappelle que personne
qui des rites ans qui est pas guéri
ce les gens ils réalisent pas à quel
point la coved ça peut être du mal a dit
merci un cruel d'axa t'arrives pas à toi
faire moi moi je savais tout votre
espoir maintenant la réadaptation
puis elle est vraiment femmes et enfants
puis retourner au travail
accès chez les gens comprennent pas la
regarder one à moi je penche pour
quelqu'un qui a été payé l'an prochain
simple citoyen la protéger vous mettez
vous des gants masques
lavez vous les mains c'est important il
va probablement rester essoufflé est-ce
qu'il va revenir complètement normal les
chansons que l'on était transformé par
la maladie il ya l'impact psychologique
mais il va rester avec l'impact physique
aussi on ne peut pas rester aux soins
intensifs deux moteurs un tube et
pendant plus d'un mois sans voir des
séquelles à long terme ça se peut un peu
prés pôles
[Musique]
donc on va mettre le club dans votre
grave on va vous endormez espace est en
hausse ce matin ont frappé deux états
s'est bien produit travailler c'est que
ça ne montre que ceux qui développent la
forme c'est vaincre
non seulement la faune pc va être
rapidement progressive ça devient
important d'agir vite d'agir bien je ne
prends des équipes comme ça qu'ils sont
très bien rodée est ce une question du
moment pour ces patients là aussi on
n'arrive pas à les assumer au bon moment
de la bonne façon un peu de thym c'est
l'arrêt cardiaque 8 201 activé sur deux
qui passe pour avoir ça ça veut dire que
tu es lo aujourd'hui ta 8 passes et
autour de toi pic touristique y en a 4
la banque et débrancher le respirateur
parce que le restera pas au repos fait
la job plus patients vont mourir pareil
en vingt ans j'ai jugé mais lui seul
autant de patients malades si malade que
ce soit avec la même maladie
c'est vraiment une première qui ont dit
mais mon dieu comme faudrait pas que ça
arrive de trois fois encore parce que le
système va finir par s'écrouler
je vois juste interminable je voudrais
mais c'est juste qu'on dirait qu'il ya
jamais de fin mais on est juste alors
que je crois que ça c'est ce que je
regrette c'est que la belle et
incroyable mobilisation de tous du début
au pas perdurer haute
je comprends que les gens sont tannés
puis moussu gitane et êtes bon jour
parfait on va respirer doucement par
l'année mais de voir des gens qui en 15
commence aux soins intensifs des décès
qui sont évitables
puis qui sont cause est quelque part par
des moments d'égocentrisme ça j'ai
beaucoup de regret pour ça une mort
inévitable
c'est triste mais on peut les
rationnaliser c'est inévitable je dis
souvent que maintenant lorsqu'on
commence les vaccins tout moore park au
vide surtout si ça a été causé par ce
que j'appelle mes petites tricheries
saint des saints qui était 100%
évidemment ça je trouve ça difficile